it was a moment of history a piece of
diplomacy and also the start of a Long
Goodbye captured in Brussels only by
photographs the article 50 letter
delivered by ambassador Sir Tim Barrow
to the EU Council President Donald Tusk
morning car plan Prime Minister for the
Prime Minister a date with destiny nine
months in the making after the
referendum it will change Britain the
powers of her office and of Parliament
forever but only if a good deal can be
negotiated she announced the legal
formality to MPs in the Commons the
article 50 process is now underway and
in accordance with the wishes of the
British people the United Kingdom is
leaving the European Union this is an
historic moment from which there can be
no turning back and sounded a
conciliatory note on cooperation a deep
and special partnership with Europe was
her promise perhaps now more than ever
the world needs the liberal democratic
values of Europe
[Applause]
signs of the splits among MPs from the
opposition benches and of domestic
battles to come in a chamber that had
been overwhelmingly remained the PM
imploring the country to get behind him
we are no longer defined by the vote we
cast but by our determination to make a
success of the result we are one great
union of people and nations with a proud
history but the opposition has promised
to fight her take on brexit the Foreign
Secretary is the same man who promised
our National Health Service 350 million
pounds a week once we left the EU now he
believes that leaving the EU EU without
a deal would be perfectly okay
it would not be perfectly okay it would
damage our economy and people's living
standards
I'm afraid that's what we see from
labour all too often talking down
Britain desperate for negotiations
and out of touch with ordinary working
people and leaving the European Union
could strain this union - what has this
government done it is carried on
blithely ignoring the views of people in
Scotland and it's democratically elected
representatives and mr. speaker Europe
is watching it one of the implications
of article 50 is putting the control of
the exit process in the hands not of
Westminster but of Brussels four times
in this letter Theresa May asks for the
negotiations on a future UK EU trade
deal to happen at the same time as the
article 50 exit negotiations and yet
within four hours Chancellor Merkel in
Berlin had said nein the exit deal first
and only after that the deal on a future
trading relationship this should have
been seen coming it does create some
difficulties the six page letter pointed
to problems ahead with a new and
controversial negotiating point saying
that if there was no deal that would
mean our cooperation in the fight
against crime and terrorism would be
weakened the first time security has
been brought in to this deal why have
you made this threat over security that
if there's no deal our cooperation in
the fight against crime and terror would
be weakened
there is absolutely no threat there is
only an observation that our fight
against crime is strengthened by the
arrangements we have with the European
Union and we need to put in place
something to replace those I'm confident
we can do that by doing that we will
keep the UK safer and the European Union
safe elsewhere in Westminster the letter
the culmination of a life's work but
UKIP's ex-leader suggesting the Prime
Minister could have been more generous
on EU citizens rights my first paragraph
would have been dear mr. tusk
we unilaterally guarantee the rights of
the 3.3 million EU citizens living in
the United Kingdom because they came
here legally only a Banana Republic
would subsequently retrospectively take
away those rising no turning back on
this new road says the Prime Minister
that potholes jams and roadworks are
already apparent
tomorrow the start of the so-called
great repeal process to make you laws
British ones for now brexit most
certainly meaning brexit vital Islam Sky
News